what would be the biggest challenge for
you to win the Sinquefield cup
traditional I don't tend to get off to a
fast start but based on the pairings
that I had in Zagreb which I thought
were highly unfavorable it's gonna be
important to get off to a good start
here because the pairings are flips are
the exact same but they should be in my
favor so getting off to a fast start I
think is gonna be critical to having a
good result I think there will be many
challenges the first one is that I'm
playing in the first round against
Magnus Cross move the black pieces well
you know I've experienced of facing
these pairs already for years and I know
that if I have my confidence and I think
oh my weight and I can handle it sort of
challenging to participate here itself
yeah but also you know I'm playing
really a lot this year and I hope I have
enough energy to play well during all
the tournaments so this probably will be
the most important to keep you know some
energy to keep some tension during all
the event and do not say fail it's
because of you know getting too tired at
some point I think first of all this
year the tournaments a bit longer so
both Croatia and here we're playing
Levin instead of 9 games that's hard on
the other hand I feel slightly more
rested than some of the participants
were to play in the rapid in blitz and
it seems like it is a very tense
tournament well for me it was the
biggest challenge is is to play a good
tournament and at least not not to lose
any single game I have six blacks and
five whites but often determine I'll
have black against Magnus and black
black in the first two games against
maximum thing we need to play just good
chest and hope Magnus Carlsen will be
not in the same form like like last one
year I mean maybe last eight months if
players like cows and didn't perform
well then we'll have some chances so the
culture I think is most suitable for
Magnus
okay if you want to win this tournament
you play better than cars and it is very
important
yeah that's obvious of course Magnus
again is unbeaten this year so of course
is the man to be beaten anytime you play
tournament with the world champion
playing you know that's that's challenge
by itself and especially dominating
world champion